it's time to dust off the Fedora and
crack the whip one more time as our
favorite globetrotting archaeologist
returns to the big screen here's
everything you need to know about
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
the last time we saw Indiana Jones he
was exploring the jungles of South
America avoiding killer and sand hanging
out with a greaser sidekick played by
Shia LaBeouf Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull hit theaters all the way back in
2008 and it was actually the second
highest grossing film of that year
worldwide but it's not exactly beloved
by hardcore Indie fans so the stakes are
pretty high for dial of Destiny which is
set to land in theaters a little over 15
years after the last adventure it was
originally supposed to be released in
July 2019 but two additional release
date changes and one pandemic later it's
finally scheduled to hit theaters on
June 30th 2023.
Indiana Jones has faced his fair share
of bad guys over the years in Crystal
Skull he was up against a group of
Soviets in South America and he narrowly
avoided having a heart to heart with a
cult leader in Temple of Doom but
there's one particular group of baddies
who cross Indy's path again and again
Nazis as it turns out Indy's not done
with the Third Reich just yet as he'll
be butting heads with some Sinister Nazi
faithful in the dial of Destiny
according to an exclusive report from
Empire magazine the film will be set in
1969 during the height of the Space Race
in both the film and in real life the
American government employed multiple
Nazi scientists to beat the Russians to
the Moon in dial of Destiny one of them
is the nefarious baller whose loyalty to
Hitler's regime remains strong according
to mass Mickelson who plays Waller he's
a man who would like to correct some of
the mistakes of the past there is
something that could make the world a
much better place to live in he would
love to get his hands on it we're
assuming that that something is the dial
of Destiny which Indy will need to find
First with the help of his goddaughter
Helena this story will also focus on
Indie truly growing old and getting
ready to take off his Fedora for good as
writer director James Mangold explained
to Empire it became really important to
me to figure out how to make this a
movie about a hero at Sunset we'll also
get some clarification on what's going
on with Shia LaBeouf's Mutt Williams
while the actor won't appear in the film
Mangold told Entertainment Weekly that
will indeed learn what happened to him
you simply can't think of Harrison Ford
without also thinking of Indiana Jones
and vice versa and Ford seems to
genuinely love playing Indie so even
though he's 80 years old he'll be
stepping onto screens for one more
go-around as Dr Jones I'd always wanted
to see Indiana Jones at the end of his
career towards the end of his life when
everything catches up to him John Reese
Davey
Davey be returning to play in best
friend Salah outside of this franchise
Rhys Davies is probably best known as
the ax wielding dwarf Gimli in The Lord
of the Rings Indy will also be teaming
up with a new character in the form of
his goddaughter Helena whom James
Mangold described to Empire as slippery
Charming the girl next door and a
grifter she'll be played by Phoebe
Waller Bridge who's best known as the
Creator and star of the sitcom fleabag
as for the big bad it'll be Mass
Mickelson as Nazi scientist valer who's
tricked the US government into thinking
he's abandoned his old ways Mickelson is
no stranger to playing antagonists as
he's delivered villainous turns in the
likes of Casino Royale Fantastic Beasts
the secrets of Dumbledore Dr Strange and
as the title cannibal on NBC's Hannibal
voller's murderous enforcer clobber will
be played by Boyd Holbrook another actor
who specializes in scary roles like
Commander Donald Pearson Logan and the
Corinthian in the Sandman in addition to
those big names Antonio Banderas is set
to show up in a cameo role plus Toby
Jones will play home Lena's dad basil
the cast will be rounded out by seanette
Renee Wilson Thomas kretchman and
bodybuilder Olivier Richters
when you think of the behind-the-scenes
Talent of Indiana Jones obviously Steven
Spielberg Springs to mind the celebrated
filmmaker directed the first four indie
films and it's almost impossible to
imagine the franchise moving on without
him however dial of Destiny won't see
Spielberg calling the shots while he
will remain on hand as a producer he
stepped away from the director's chair
so that a younger filmmaker could take
the reins that leaves the dial of
Destiny in the very capable hands of
James Mangold who should be a great fit
the story is supposedly about an aging
Indie going on one last adventure before
riding off into the sunset and Mangold
has some promising experience in that
area he co-wrote and directed 2017's
Logan which is the acclaimed swan song
to 20th century Fox's version of
Wolverine
look
I gotta go in addition to Logan
mangold's credits include the Western
310 to Yuma the crime drama Copland the
Johnny Cash biopic walk the line and the
sports drama Ford V Ferrari
when it comes to film composers there's
none more famous than John Williams Jaws
Jurassic Park Star Wars E.T Harry Potter
and Superman are just a sampling of his
iconic pieces he even came up with a
theme for the Olympics Williams is also
responsible for the rousing scores that
accompany Indiana Jones on each of his
adventures and he'll be back for dial of
Destiny providing music that's sure to
get the blood pumping as Indie traverses
the globe once again interestingly at
one point in time Williams implied that
the fablemans and dial of Destiny would
be his last projects before retiring
however in January 2023 he walks those
statements back as he explained I'll
stick around for a while I can't retire
from music a day without music is a
mistake
the teaser for Indiana Jones and the
dial of Destiny dropped in December 2022
and promised all sorts of Adventures for
our aging hero when the preview starts
it seems that Indy has been living the
quiet life of a college professor as an
exchange between him and Salah makes
clear his old friend laments that he
misses waking up in anticipation of the
exciting Adventures promised by each new
day
come and gone perhaps perhaps not but
while Dr Jones may be done with
Adventure Adventure isn't quite done
with Dr Jones as the teaser progresses
we see Andy picking up his whip getting
in a showdown Atop A train and exploring
ruins filled with Greek statues he also
makes his way through a Nazi castle and
an exciting chase at a ticker tape
parade for the Apollo 11 astronauts the
whole time he regales us with his unique
world view as he declares I don't
believe in magic but a few times in my
life I've seen things things I can't
explain I've come to believe it's not so
much what you believe it's how hard you
believe in in April 2023 we were finally
treated to the full official trailer
which is scored to the classic rolling
stone song Sympathy for the Devil That
Tune makes it clear that Indy is a man
outside of time in the Strange World of
the 1960s speaking of time it's possible
that that theme might play a big part in
the film as Valor explains why he wants
to get his hands on the dial of Destiny
Hitler made mistakes and with this I
will correct
could time travel somehow factor into
all of this is that why so many people
want the dial not only are the Nazis
after it not only is Indy trying to get
it but it also looks like Helena has an
agenda of her own as she too is trying
to get her hands on this precious
artifact this prompts a three-way Chase
across the world complete with undersea
exploration and aerial action all in the
pursuit of something that could very
well change the course of history
Harrison Ford is obviously a Hollywood
Legend but he's also still just a mortal
who ages like everyone else he's 80
years old and he presumably can't run
around beating up Nazis forever plenty
of us thoughts that he would hang up the
Fedora for good after Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull but here he goes again and
what surely must be the final Adventure
in an interview with total film in April
2023 Ford revealed this is the final
film in the series and this is the last
time I'll play the character I
anticipate that it will be the last time
that he appears in a film for me this is
it
you've told me that too and Anne Jones
granted that claim may be a little naive
on Ford's part if Hollywood can find a
way to reboot this franchise or start a
prequel series they will however we do
believe Ford when he says that this is
the last time he'll play Indie and if it
sounds like we're crying that's just the
dust from all those ancient artifacts in
our eyes
de-aging technology is a great tool but
its uses in film thus far have been a
bit wonky the Irishman for example is a
fantastic movie with a terrific Robert
De Niro performance but those scenes
with him as a younger man just look
plain weird however it sounds like dial
of Destiny is taking de-aging technology
to the next level While most of the
movie will be set during the late 60s
the opening act will take place during
World War II this segment will
reportedly run for 25 minutes which
means that James Mangold must have
plenty of faith in the de-aging tech if
we're going to be looking at an
artificially youthful Harrison Ford for
nearly half an hour as Mangold gushed to
Total film it was an incredible
technology the goal was to give the
audience a full-bodied taste of what
they missed so much from the clips we've
seen of the opening sequence Ford looks
pretty fantastic and better even than
recent examples of de-aging like Sean
Young And Blade Runner 2049 or Kurt
Russell in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
2. evidently the jump from the 40s to
the 60s is going to be key to the story
and dial of Destiny the film will be
hopping from an era when it was clear
who the bad guys were to a much more
complicated time as Mangold told The
Hollywood Reporter it's not just a movie
about a hero in his Twilight years who
is called back into action it's more
than just that his bones might ache it's
that his soul might ache or that some of
his optimism or sense of fitting into
the world might have evaporated
furthermore Indy will be dealing with a
body that's much older and creakier than
before slugging bad guys in the face
isn't going to be as easy as it once was
with Mangold explaining it reminds the
audience of the contrast between a hero
and his physical prime and a hero at 70.
we're not relying solely on the
audience's memory of the previous films
it reminds everyone what he's done what
he survived what he's accomplished by
showing him in his most hearty and then
finding him at 70 in New York City it
produces for the audience a Kind of
Wonderful Whiplash of how they're going
to have to readjust and retool their
brains for this guy he's about to retire
yes from being a professor yes and all
hell braces it does
this fifth Indiana Jones film has been
in development for a long time even all
even all the way back in the 1970s
George Lucas and Steven Spielberg hoped
to tell a quintet of stories about the
globetrotting adventurer and after
having waited so long after the Last
Crusade to make Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull it didn't seem like another big
screen outing could ever happen but
following Crystal skull's release Lucas
began researching possible story ideas
as he told the Times online in 2008 I'm
in the future Stevens in the past he's
trying to drag it back to the way they
were I'm trying to push it to a whole
different place so still we have a sort
of tension the project was stuck in
development for years before Lucas sold
lucasfilm to Disney who hoped to revive
the series without him at that point
Spielberg and Crystal Skull writer David
kep began working on the script for what
would eventually become dial of Destiny
by 2018 Spielberg was preoccupied with
other projects and kep was replaced by
solo Rider Jonathan Caston son of
Raiders of the Lost Ark scribe Lawrence
Kasdan before returning quickly
thereafter eventually Spielberg's
version of Indiana Jones 5 failed
because he Harrison Ford and Disney
couldn't all agree on the script when
James mangold's took the helm things
seemed to be back on track he rewrote
kept script alongside his Ford V Ferrari
writers brothers jez and John Henry
Butterworth with all four men receiving
final written by credits
following the sale of lucasfilm George
Lucas distanced himself from both Star
Wars and Indiana Jones after Disney
declined to use his treatments for the
Star Wars sequel Trilogy his involvement
in the Space Opera franchise has been
essentially non-existent besides
visiting the set of the Mandalorian he's
effectively bit his former glories
goodbye while Lucas wrote and directed
Star Wars during his time as a filmmaker
he was never actually a credited
screenwriter for any Indiana Jones movie
instead he helped craft the story for
each film served as a producer and
worked closely with Spielberg to make
sure that their shared Vision became a
reality but while Lucas's involvement in
the fifth Indiana Jones has been
diminished following his sale to Disney
he's still in the loop according to
James Mangold both Spielberg and Lucas
are involved with dial of Destiny while
they may not be in the director's chair
or receiving any story credit to these
two filmmaking Giants just had to be
included in another Indiana Jones
picture especially if it's going to be
the final one serving as executive
producers Spielberg and Lucas have
continued to help curate Hollywood's
most famous archaeologist from afar
which is surely comforting to plenty of
loyal fans if they trust Mangold to
deliver a killer version of Indiana
Jones then the rest of us probably
shouldn't be too worried
since he directed the first four Indiana
Jones movies one can't help but wonder
how Steven Spielberg feels about dial of
Destiny he's been the primary creator of
the character for decades so in Indiana
Jones movie without him is sort of
impossible to even imagine
oh dear of course the filmmaker is still
involved and serves as an executive
producer alongside George Lucas but he
isn't working as closely as he used to
this time around but regardless of his
time or lack thereof on set Spielberg is
still the authority on all things
Indiana Jones which makes his thoughts
on dial of Destiny all the more exciting
after watching the film at a Disney
executive screening he told variety when
the lights came up I just turned to the
group and said damn I thought I was the
only one who knew how to make one of
these everybody loved the movie it's
really really a good Indiana Jones film
I'm really proud of what Mangold has
done with it that's High Praise coming
from a man who single-handedly directed
all of this character's previous
on-screen adventures with Spielberg
clearly on board with this version our
hopes for dial of Destiny have only
risen giving this installment the
potential for this to be one of the best
of the series
with Indy's favorite Egyptian excavator
Salah returning for dial of Destiny many
have wondered if other fan favorites
could return as well among the most
requested is kihui Kwan's Short Round
from 1984's Temple of
Dooms
before recently Quan was best known for
his work as Short Round And as data in
The Goonies which was released the
following year but then in 2022 he
returned to International stardom thanks
to the success of the multiversal action
comedy drama everything everywhere all
at once he played Waymond Wong which
earned him an Academy Award for best
supporting actor after years away from
the big screen Quan is suddenly doing
quite well for himself in 2022 Quan and
Harrison Ford shared a tearful reunion
at Disney's d23 convention but alas Juan
has insisted that he isn't returning for
dial of Destiny he told Entertainment
Tonight in April I want to say I'll be
in it but no here's the thing I don't
want to disappoint the fans I've joked
about it all the time but reuniting with
Harrison after 38 years that was very
special with this being Ford's final
adventurous Indie and Quan unlikely to
return a short round for a potential
spin-off it seems like fans will just
have to settle for the off-screen
reunion
as Indy's original love interest Karen
Allen's Marion Ravenwood is the only
recurring female character in the
Indiana Jones chronology first appearing
in Raiders of the Lost Ark she and Dr
Jones share a steamy romantic history
upon reuniting they resumed their
previous Affairs at least for a while
since Temple of Doom took place a year
before the events of Raiders and the
Last Crusade focused mainly on Indy's
relationship with his father Marion
wasn't in either of the first two
sequels but then Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull came along with Alan appearing
with their son and managing to finally
put a ring on the elderly
archaeologist's finger when Spielberg
and Lucas first began developing the
fifth Indiana Jones film Allen initially
expressed interest in returning as
Marion once more as she told MovieWeb in
2011 I mean we're married now so it
would be difficult I think to move
forward without her but ever since
there's been no official comment
regarding Allen's inclusion in dial of
Destiny though James Mangold has
confirmed that we'll learn more about
what happened to her and Indie sunmat
we've heard nothing more about her own
status with Alan's seemingly radio
silent we can only speculate about
whether or not she'll show up in the
Final Chapter after all do you and
Harrison talk do you stay in contact we
talk every now and then for nearly 30
years the Indiana Jones series was
distributed by the motion picture giant
Paramount Pictures after Spielberg and
Lucas made a deal for five Indiana Jones
pictures with the distributor the
Studio's famous mountain logo has
appeared at the beginning of each Indie
flick from 1981's Raiders of the Lost
Ark all the way to 2008's Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull it's now pretty much
synonymous with Harrison Ford's
globetrotting Adventures alas nothing in
Hollywood lasts forever so after
lucasfilm was sold to the Walt Disney
Company in 2012 Paramount's involvement
in any future Indiana Jones installments
was subject to change and that change
has in fact happened Paramount has
retained its initial distribution rights
for the first four films in the series
which is why they're currently available
on Paramount plus and not Disney plus
but the house of mouse now owns
distribution rights to any future films
dial of Destiny is is a co-production
between lucasfilm and Disney making it
the first Indiana Jones film not solely
produced by lucasfilm but Paramount has
received an associate credit on this
latest picture with an undisclosed
Financial participation as well how this
all works behind the scenes is a bit of
a mystery but it's clear that the
cooperation between Disney and Paramount
has only helped Indiana Jones going
forward still replacing the snow-capped
mountain with the Disneyland castle will
surely be pretty hard for moviegoers to
adjust to
unlike a lot of other action films the
Indiana Jones series wasn't released in
strict chronological order while dial of
Destiny is the final feature in The Saga
parts of it fit between some of Indy's
other earlier Adventures the first film
chronologically in the Indie timeline is
Temple of Doom which takes place in 1935
only a year later the events of Raiders
of the Lost Ark unfold which see Indy
and Marion fight a group of Nazis in
search of the Old Testament Relic known
as the Ark of the Covenant the Last
Crusade takes place a few years after
that in 1939 but not before a flashback
to Indy's time as a Young Man played by
River Phoenix said in 1912. this is as
far back in the past that the feature
films have ventured thus far this should
be in a museum Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull was released in 2008 but it takes
place in 1957 during the Cold War a
somewhat older Indie finds his long-lost
son mutt marries Marion and discovers
the existence of extraterrestrial or
rather interdimensional creatures as for
dial of Destiny though there will be
flashbacks tonight 1944 it will
reportedly mostly be set in 1969. thus
it will be the farthest forward India
has ever ventured in the 20th century
described by director James Mangold as a
hero at Sunset Indy's Fifth and final
big screen Adventure is set to be his
Swan Song and while that's sad on some
level there's plenty of mystery and
excitement with such a promise Mangold
is possibly best known for directing the
final two installments of Fox's
Wolverine Trilogy so he's no stranger to
telling an action Hero's final tale
2017's Logan closed the book on Hugh
Jackman's long-running turn as the
iconic X-Man at least until Marvel
Studios introduced the idea of him
returning again that film pretty much
told the definitive Wolverine story for
a generation so fans are anxious to see
if dial of Destiny will employ the same
tone and effectively serve as indie's
version of Logan as Mangold rhetorically
asked Entertainment Weekly what does the
hero do when the world no longer has a
place for him I find it really
interesting to try to look at classical
Heroes through the prism of our jaundice
contemporary attitudes the best version
of this movie was the one that didn't do
everything like all the other movies
Mangold also compared to dial of Destiny
to Logan while reassuring fans that the
film's tone would remain faithful to the
Indiana Jones Mythos he further noted I
am under no illusions that my job making
an Indiana Jones film was to suddenly
beat the humor out of it and turn it
into some kind of dirge I think that
what we're trying to do is balance both
an accurate and realistic appraisal of
where this character would be at this
time in his life and do that honestly
this is an Indiana Jones film
after Disney bought lucasfilm in 2012
fans wondered how the house of mouse
would continue the Indiana Jones
franchise while Star Wars has been
Disney's main lucasfilm priority
following the sale projects like dial of
Destiny and the Disney plus series
Willow prove that there's more to
lucasfilm's catalog than just Star Wars
after dial of Destiny was greenlit and
it was announced that this would be
Harrison Ford's last outing many
speculated that Disney would attempt to
reboot the franchise through a series of
prequels and for a while that looked
like a real possibility in 2022 variety
reported that a prequel series set
before the events of Raiders of the Lost
Ark and probably Temple of Doom was in
the works at Disney plus but by 2023
other sources implied that the series
which would have been the first Indie
prequel since the young Indiana Jones
Chronicles had been scrapped entirely
then in April Screen Rant reported that
dial of Destiny would close out the
franchise for good while this news
sounds pretty final recent years have
proven that nothing is permanent in
Hollywood and while we shouldn't expect
a reboot anytime soon it would actually
be surprising if Disney and lucasfilm
never returned to the world of Indiana
Jones ever again
[Music]